الحرب في اوكرانيا كشفت الاختلاف الواضح
والتارخي بين دول شرق اوروبا وغربها خاصه
ان دول شرق اوروبا كانت لسنوات والفتره
الحرب البارده جزء من محور حلف وارسو
بقياده الاتحاد السوفيتي لكن بعد انهيار
الاتحاد وانضمام عدد كبير من هذه الدول
الى حلف الناتو تحولت هذه الدول وباتت حتى
اكثر تشددا وعدائيه لروسيا من نظيراتها
الغربيه ربما هذا التشدد اثر على قرارات
النيتو وكذلك على قرارات دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي التي تشددت اكثر منذ اندلاع على
الحرب في اوكرانيا حول هذا الموضوع وكذلك
الابعاد الامنيه
والدفاعيه للافكار التي تتبناها بعض الدول
في اوروبا الشرقيه على الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك على حلف الناتو معنى السيده فيلينا
تشاكاروبا مديره معهد النمسا للدراسات
الاوروبيه والامنيه اولا السيدات شكا اهلا
بك معنا في عسكريتاريا يعني لماذا كل هذا
التشدد من قبل بعض الدول في اوروبا التي
كانت حليفه لروسيا في السابق وضمن حلف
وارسو
هذا الموقف المتشدد الذي تتبناه بلدان
اوروبا الشرقيه له جذور جيو سياسيه
وتاريخيه وهو موقف لم يتغير كثيرا طيله
العقود الثلاثه الماضيه لان هذه البلدان
كانت ترى في روسيا اكبر تهديد امنيا وجيوس
سياسيا لسلامه اراضيها وسيادتها وخلال
فتره الثلاثين عاما الماضيه ظلت الضمانات
الامنيه التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده الى
جانب حلف الناتو تمثل الاولويه القصوى
بالنسبه الى هذه البلدان بعد خروجها من
حلف وارسو وانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي اضحى
المهمه الاولى التي تحظى بالاهتمام لدى
هذه البلدان هي الحصول على ضمانات امنيه
وسبيل الوحيد لتحقيق ذلك برايها كان
الحصول على العضويه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
لضمان حصولها على الحمايه الامريكيه
الدائمه اما بالنسبه لاندماجها في
المنظومه الاوروبيه فقد احتلت هذه المساله
المرتبه الثانيه وبعد مرور 30 عاما نرى
نفس الموقف المتشدد تتبناه بلدان اوروبا
الشرقيه التي لا ترى ان فرنسا والمانيا
التي تمثلان المحرك لعمليه التكامل في
اوروبا فضلا عن وجود سياسه للامن والدفاع
لدى اوروبا التي ينظر اليها على انها اليه
ذات مصداقيه فيما يخص توفير الامن لضمان
سلامه اراضي هذه البلدان التي رغم ذلك لا
تزال ترى في الولايات المتحده وحلف الناتو
الجهه الوحيده الكفيله بتوفير الامن لها
سيده شكاروفا يعني الكثير من دول اوروبا
الشرقيه استبدلت الاسلحه السوفيتيه التي
كانت تمتلكها في السابق الان باسلحه
امريكيه واوروبيه لكن الى اي مدى جيوش هذه
الدول المؤهله للتعامل بالعقيده الغربيه
التي انتجت اصلا هذه الاسلحه
اولا وقبل كل شيء واجهت هذه البلاد خلال
المرحله الانتقاليه اوضاعا اقتصاديه بالغه
الصعوبه وكان عليها تعزيز قدراتها
الدفاعيه تدريجيا في وقت كانت فيه اغلبيه
هذه البلدان تعتمد على المعدات العسكريه
في الحقبه السوفياتيه وفي ظل الحقائق
الجديده في اوروبا عام 2023
عمدت معظم هذه البلدان وبطريقه غير
متناسبه مع ناتجها المحلي الاجمالي
وميزانيه الدفاع لديها الى ارسال مساعدات
عسكريه وذخائر الى اوكرانيا يعود الكثير
منها الى الحاقبه السوفياتيه لانه بوسع
الاوكرانيين التعامل مع هذه الانواع من
منظومات الاسلحه وهذا ما يجعل بلدان
اوروبا شرقيه بحاجه الى ان يعاد تزويدها
بالمعدات العسكريه على وجه التحديد ان
مسعى هذه البلدان لشراء اسلحه غربيه سواء
كانت امريكيه صنع اوروبيه او حتى اسيويه
تكمن اهميته في قابليه التشغيل البيني
لهذه المنظومات مع المنظومات الامريكيه
علما انها تعهدت بزياده حجم انفاقها على
الدفاع في ميزانيتها حتى قبل بدء الحرب
وكان الامر يتعلق انذاك بحسم مسائل
عملياتيه واختيارات معينه حيث ان اوروبا
لا توجد لديها صناعه دفاع مشتركه لذلك لا
تزال الدول الاعضاء تنظر في الخيارات
الملائمه لاحتياجاتها الوطنيه
سيده شكاروفا يعني بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهذا الدمار الكبير الذي حدث الا تحتاج
بعض هذه الدول الى مراجعه مواقفها
الاستراتيجيه وكذلك موقفها الدفاعيه وانها
بحاجه الى اللجوء الى بعض الحياد السياسي
ربما التي يؤمنها من اي هجوم في المستقبل
ام ان هذه الدول ستتخذ المزيد من المواقف
المتشدده في المستقبل وكيف سينعكس ذلك
اصلا
لا اعتقد ان موقف هذه البلدان تحديدا سوف
يتغير تجاه روسيا اولا لانها كانت على
صواب تماما في تقييمها للاوضاع والتحذيرات
التي اطلقتها بشان ما قد تقدم عليه لاعاده
رسم خارطه اوروبا الجيوسيه وثانيا بسبب
الحقائق الجو السياسيه ففي حال نجحت روسيا
في الحرب التي تشمها على اوكرانيا فان
موسكو سوف تعيد صياغه البنيه الامنيه في
اوروبا برمتها وقد نشهد ظهور جدار حديدي
جديد ونشوب حرب بارده مجددا على اراضي
القاره العجوز عندها سوف تصبح هذه البلدان
تحديدا في خطوط الدفاع الاولى لحلف النيتو
لانها تقع على حدود روسيا كما انها قد
تهاجم بلدان اوروبيه اخرى مثل مولدوفا
وجورجيا لضم المزيد من اراضيها من ناحيه
اخرى لو لدى بلدان اوروبا الشرقيه الرغبه
في اي واصل الغرب تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
سيتعين عليها التمسك بموقفها المتشدد
ودعني اذكرك بان فرنسا والمانيا كانتا
تخودان غماره تقارب جيوسياسيا مع روسيا
قبل بدء الحرب وكانت متحمسه لتطبيع
العلاقات معها من اجل تموقع افضل لاوروبا
في الصراع بين الصين والولايات المتحده
حتى لو اعتبرنا ان نتيجه الحرب سوف تكون
في مصلحه اوكرانيا فان ذلك سوف يتطلب تبني
موقف متشدد ايضا من جانب بلدان اوروبا
الشرقيه والسبب يعود الى ان هذه البلدان
ذاتها ستصر على انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف
النيتو لانه السبيل الوحيد في نظرها كي
تحصل اوكرانيا على ضمانات امنيه لانها لا
تعتبر ان ما تقدمه فرنسا او المانيا او
الاتحاد الاوروبي من ضمانات سوف يكون
كفيلا بحمايه سلامه اراضي وسياده اوكرانيا
مستقبلا بالتالي في كلا السيناريوهين سواء
انتصرت اوكرانيا او نجحت روسيا سوف تكون
هذه البلدان على الحدود المباشره بين
معسكرين امنيين ودفاعيين متصارعين وهذا ما
لا يجعل موقفها قابلا للتغيير في المستقبل
السيده تشكروا في ظل هذا الزخم الذي بات
يتمتع به حلف الناتو في هذه المرحله هل
تعتقدين بانه فكره تشكيل قوه اوروبيه
مشتركه مطروحه او ما زالت مطروحه ام انها
اصبحت فكره بلا جدوى
انشاء جيش اوروبي كانت قبل كل شيء تعبيرا
طنانا استخدمته وسائل الاعلام بهدف زياده
مبيعاتها لم يكن هناك على الاطلاق اي افاق
عمليه لتشكيل جيش اوروبي ثانيا ما ينبغي
مناقشته وفكره او ما يسمى بالاستقلاليه
الاستراتيجيه الاوروبيه وهو ما يمثل في
الواقع طموحا عبرت عنه كل من باريس و
برلين وبروكسيل للحصول على استقلاليه
استراتيجيه في مجال السياسه الامنيه
والدفاعيه الاوروبيه ما يعني ان تتمكن
اوروبا من معالجه صراعاتها العسكريه
والحروب التي تدل رحاها في القاره العجوز
والاحداث التي شهدناها العمل منصرم اثبتت
ان الامر ليس كذلك حيث لا تزال اوروبا
تعتمد الى حد كبير على الدعم الامريكي
الذي لولاه لاستسلمت اوكرانيا في مراحل
الحرب الاولى وقد على ارض الواقع ان
المساعده الامريكيه هي التي جاءت اولا
وتبعتها المساعده العسكريه الاوروبيه وما
ساعد اوكرانيا على الصمود في المرحله
الاولى من الحرب كانت المساعدات الامريكيه
قبل اي شيء اخر بالنسبه لي مساله
الاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه لاوروبا قد حسمت
تقريبا ولا ارى في الاجل القصير اي افاق
لتمكن المؤسسات الاوروبيه والدول الاعضاء
في الاتحاد الاوروبي من طرح اي خطه
مستدامه لتحقيق هذه الاستقلاليه
الاستراتيجيه وقد ينتهي بنا الامر الى
حاله من التشظي وظهور معسكرات داخل حلف
النيتو لان بلدان اوروبا الوسطى والشرقيه
سوف تواصل الاعتماد على المظله الامنيه
التي توفرها الولايات المتحده والنيتو
مقابل المعسكر الفرنسي الالماني الحريص
على التكامل الاوروبي الذي سوف يواصل
انتهاج سياسه طموحه اكبر لتحقيق
الاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه
والتساؤل الكبير لديه هو ما شكل التصادم
الذي سوف يحدث بين هذين المفهومين
الكبيرين في المستقبل واي منهما سوف ينتصر
انا ارى ان السيناريو الاكثر واقعيه هو
تعزيز الركيز الاوروبيه داخل حلف شمال
الاطلسي
السيده فيلينا تشاكا روفا مديره معهد
النمسا للدراسات الاوروبيه والامنيه شكرا
جزيلا على هذه التوضيحات